hello and welcome to a spoiler free
review of star wars the force awakens
I'm rob this is Tony over at a comic
line editor in chief yep yeah overall
look you know maybe let's just kick it
off with like how did you feel walking
out of this year I mean first of all
like many people I was I was scared I
was nervous I was like you know there's
so much height I was like how you know
we we got burned by the prequels but
coming out of it and I loved it yeah and
it's definitely gonna see it again yeah
they get I know you're gonna see it like
18 times three more times exactly i felt
extremely satisfied they to say that
very least you know JJ played it really
safe you get i was fulfilled walking out
but let's kind of breakdown in different
areas your review is up on gamespot but
let's kind of go over that a little bit
the characters the new characters the
old characters you know there's lots of
different ones that you'll remember and
see the characters that are introduced
they're very unique and you even
mentioned like who was your favorite and
I immediately just started listing every
one of them yeah cuz cuz it to me it
felt like all right you're gonna give
these these you know actors that we know
these characters little cameos but you
really trying to introduce these new
characters so they can carry the
franchise forward but they did a great
job with these character because I love
them all they're all great I want to see
them more and and there is a great mix
between one when they interacted because
it felt natural and you know you have to
bring new ones to meet with the old when
Z and sometimes I felt like it was a
little fast which awesome like boom okay
this character is with this character
but they did a great job and I can't
wait to see you know now we got to wait
two years yeah the humor of them
the movie the humor was great I laughed
at every joke yeah they did a great time
they nailed every delivery right every
moment the issue that we both had was
there was so much of it so it's like you
know did they cross the line or do they
hold it just right and there there has
been he were in other movies you know
there are those moments but you know
maybe it's a little risky for him to do
so much she murder but he's like this is
my movie so you know he's gonna own it
and he's gonna do it and we're
nitpicking I mean it's just you know if
we're trying to find things so whether
it's too much or just right I mean it's
you can easily overlook it and that was
fine and that's the thing was is it
wasn't bad humor it was just a lot of it
like you I would have liked to have felt
maybe you know after a grave or dire
situation to have let that soak for a
while like you but it's not like gardens
of galaxies where it's just like wacky
over the top I mean it was just a little
moments and again it worked it it felt
natural CGI was so yeah perfect and NFL
different because you know that there
were some moments as like oh you know
it's a Star Wars movie so we know
certain things going to happen but the
way they were filmed way there you know
edited and just the angles it felt
different even though it was similar
because you know you got x-wings of TIE
fighters but it wasn't just a rehash
like how do we do it here it's like
let's try to do it again so it I really
like that again it's it's standing on
its own but it you know it's a Star Wars
movie musical score oh yeah and I'm yeah
thank goodness we got John Williams
again yeah at work and yeah it's it
that's what you need
yeah so overall it was great it was
great I mean you're gonna love it it's
not perfect yeah it's it's pretty much
everything a star wars fan good one yeah
there were moments in this movie that
like little tear my eyes yeah I mean
yeah we mentioned the humor it's not all
like you know laughing and you know
there's there are moments where you're
on edge of your seat yeah you feel the
suspense or whether you're happy or sad
or I mean it's all there so yeah so
that's all we got hands up yeah we're
done be sure to check it out opens
December eighteenth this week and for
all of your Star Wars news to get a
gamespot com